[Applause]
oh my gosh i've been such a fan of yours
for a long time
and i'm just so happy for each and every
one of your successes may i start with
that oh
thank you likewise the same same thank
you
i mean you're such a famous singer and
then you decide to get on tick-tock
you want to innovate you want to raise
the game and make it interesting
44 million followers
unprecedented a billion likes
i appreciate that thank you now you have
these things called um
millie meals what are you telling me
about yeah so
it started off as uh you know
me you know trying different recipes
because you know we at home and i didn't
i had to figure out where to put you
know my creativity and i've never been a
cook so
like you know it's it's this is
definitely something new that happened
in the pandemic
so what i started doing is putting all
of my favorite things
into one dish and uh and then i started
calling them millie mills and i told the
fans that every time
that i reached a new million i would do
some kind of recipe
but i didn't imagine that it was gonna
be you know
every week or so now we love to try
celebrity approved weird food combos on
our show it's sort of a running theme we
have and i was wondering if you would be
up
to try some of them with us oh
absolutely this is my favorite thing to
do
all right well we can't have a weird
foods tasting
without our friend and culinary
contributor
he's also in the million-follower
tick-tock club it's
ayton burna hello hi drew
hi jason i am so excited
by the way jason just took his shirt off
and got ready to eat so i'm excited i'm
gonna leave my shirt on and eat
are you eitan i was gonna take my vest
off okay we're getting comfy
well i'm really excited eitan is gonna
be sharing
two celebrity approved weird dishes and
he always brings it
and then jason as the third and final
step
is gonna teach us how to make something
jason
whoa i'm not gonna lie i'm scared me too
and just stick around because you won't
want to miss it it's
a salmon smoothie words i
i never i don't think those words need
to be together but they are i
don't know if like my gag reflexes are
gonna let this happen but i'm going to
try it
like because that's how much i love you
jason i'm really excited also like
look at you you just tell me what i mean
it works
i mean a ton take it away what's our
first weird food comment okay awesome so
first up
we are going to be having something from
channing tatum people magazine reported
that he likes to have peanut butter
jelly and cheeto sandwiches
now he gives very specific instructions
it's a normal amount of peanut butter
then you're ready for this take your
cheetos
and you're going to crush them onto the
peanut butter
all right i see jason's bacon his um and
he also specifies that you put the
cheetos on the peanut butter and then
the jelly on top of that well because
the peanut butter is kind of an adhesive
yes jason are you excited to try this
weird food combo
oh i i think this one is actually going
to be good for some reason
are you going home jason are you cutting
um i'm gonna i'm gonna take the whole
thing down
perfect us two okay are you ready one
two here we go
oh i love the crown mmm
wow oh well now i'm getting to the
cheetos
there's only one way you come up with
this recipe high
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i'll give that a yes out of 10. no next
up jason and drew we have
according to the huffington post beyonce
when she was pregnant with blue ivy
dipped bananas into ketchup all right
now to be fair to beyonce
because we don't want to offend queen
bee but she denies these rumors but
regardless i feel like we have to try it
oh that actually looks terrible that
display right there that display is
terrible
by the way you're right wow it is
totally
like murder on the
you know what it is it's like a shrimp
uh oh my god like the cocktail drink
it's like a shrimp cocktail
yes definitely it's banana cocktail on
your marks
get set dip
all right here we go
i don't like to eat my bananas like that
i ain't got to fill it up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
jason has left the studio that's a no
for me that
was disgusting sorry guys
no jason it's
you know what it's a good tea up um
to this one um okay jason
take us through something i've been
thinking about
for weeks in anticipation of this
segment
so this is supposed to be a meal
replacement
right so um by blending the salmon it
kind of eliminates
you know the the chewing and then it's
it's liquid
right so it's easily digestible okay so
salmon
you put water in there eight ounces of
water
yep um
i saw some tabasco i'm the most excited
about this
okay i mean okay here we go all right
these
okay we're gonna put aside perfect okay
ready here we go
[Applause]
how are you not to bring that out
that deserves a round of applause
that's better than that that's better
than banana ketchup for sure you know
what
i will tell you something it's better
than the banana and the ketchup
oh my gosh you guys this was the most
fun
weird food combos we've ever done i
can't thank you enough eitan
always you are my partner in weird food
combo crime and the culinary world in
general
[Music]
you